today's topic the call me carson issue
so if you aren't aware call me carson is
a streamer or twitch streamer
youtuber who makes very popular videos
on minecraft and he was involved in a
controversy which alleges that
he was involved with an underage person
a young girl
two young women who were 17. now this
whole thing blew up
carson ended up disappearing some of the
people that he worked with
uh ended up going on some drama channels
and exposing him
and i'm like all right okay well this
sounds like terrible stuff let me look
into it
turns out that all this drama were all
there around the 17 year old girls are
interesting
because call me carson when he was
involved with him was 19.
and they was trying to cancel him
because at 19 he was involved with the
17 year old
all right
at 19 he was involved with a 17 year old
bastard she was trying to groom her yes
he was in the 12th grade she was in the
10th grade that shit's illegal
it's illegal
[Music]
is
listen what i just said was
i almost don't want to like i don't feel
like i want to
talk about this this is so dumb just the
mere fact
that we have to explain this to people
and to some people
if it's illegal it's a lego
so let's say i'm um for example this my
girlfriend is 17 and i'm 18
because you know me my girl we have four
months apart
she's in the she's born in the month of
whatever i'm born in the month of
whatever i'm older than her by four
months
we started going out together i was
going to turn 16 sushi but there's like
a four month buffer
where we was illegal same year
four months so where do you draw the
line yeah but it's two years
what's so much the difference you're
always ready
to say that girls mature faster than
boys
but then the 19 cannot go out with a 17
and to be fair who
cares then again where do you draw the
line i don't know
i don't have the answers but two years
we're making a whole fuss
and a whole cancellation calling names
for people
for two years it's like let's say even
a 10 year old was going out with a 12.
don't act like the 12 year old is grown
grown no i'm not trying to excuse this
all those good people are going to jump
on that wagon and here wait
your apologies her apologies think with
your brain two seconds
bruh just think it's not with your
outrage
with your brain this is a it's america
this is america
it's facts twitter has ruined a whole
generation
definitely they've learned about these
abstract concepts and and try to apply
it literally to every situation
as if it makes sense oh uh asian consent
and 19 to 17
and then the other thing that they say
was like well okay yeah the age thing is
not an issue
but but he's popular
and they're not you know the power and
balance thing has got to be one of the
dumbest ideas
so what i can never be involved with
somebody who admires me
so what am i supposed to pick somebody
who's never and just doesn't have heard
never heard of it
what about if we get in a relationship
and then they find out and then they
feel very inferior
is there a power imbalance am i taking
advantage of her what if i get into a
relationship we're married for multiple
years
and then i get an absolute amazing shape
while she gets out there's a power
balance because she feels deeply
insecure and she feels like she'll never
mess her up and she starts to get
jealous like
power and bounces exist in every dynamic
it's not inherently it's not inherently
predatory to be involved with somebody
like
these concepts i think they sound like
they make sense they're stupid
they're not interested concepts because
people talk about power dynamics like
they always matter like
if there's a power difference well we
got
unless it's your boss i don't care
even unless it's like you're you're
you're correctional officer
unless it's like the police officer
who's arresting you or the lawyer who's
prosecuting you
or someone who can have direct control
over your basic human rights and your
livelihood
i do not care you are a grown ass person
if you want to go with a celebrity you
have the right to who am i to tell you
you can't
the girl's name sugar so what am i only
supposed to date other celebrities is
that it or other youtubers on a
comparable level what if i date a
youtuber who's got a hundred million
subscribers
pewdiepie
what i was trying to say is i said 100
million i'm like wait who has 100
million and then
there's t-series which i don't want to
be in a relationship with 100 people
anyways it's not that important pause
big pause
my whole point is that this this
rhetoric is is
nonsense it's a bunch of new ways cause
the point is you're a hoe
you ready to oh you i'm sugary because i
just
act but you say that you want to go out
with a [ __ ] for
for the for the views you're a ho ho
i don't know i don't know i just wanted
to call you i said 100 million and i
thought like who was youtuber there's
only one
so
i think this kind of rhetoric is is is
plain silly it's it's ideas that were
born from a real problem in life
but these ideas don't actually have
applicable uses in most situations
this idea that because it's an inherent
power dynamic like yes women
traditionally like dudes who
make more than them are taller are
bigger like women like to date up a lot
of the times it is what it is
are you going to deny them that agency
and that choice to make that because you
feel like they're somehow
something predatory who are you to
decide that and by you infiltrating this
idea into their heads you're inherently
making them victims of situations where
they felt very comfortable and now you
guys are trying to cancel young people
for decisions that they made with other
young folks 19 and 17
really what about 18 and 16 is that also
a problem
17 and 15 is that also a problem what
about 18 and 20
let's say she was 17 the next day she
turns 18. is it now illegal
one day difference like some of this
stuff is so silly
and arbitrary and people sound so
indignant
they sound so proud to be like you're
disgusting
you're a pig like like they're so sure
when the difference can be a matter of
weeks
months and you guys act like there's
such a change between those two points
it's crazy people will be like yay take
your 15 000
loan to go to university at 17 but if
you want to bang a 19 year old you don't
have the agency
you're a vic brah miss me miss me
i don't know carson i don't know these
people involved but this rhetoric that
we got going on needs to die
the power dynamics that you were talking
about remove the the moment of account
hours of the week i was that was it's
crazy because
i feel and it's a feeling maybe maybe
it's not real but i hear a lot of
womanists using that rhetoric of power
dynamics
right but i look at it and it's the
least
womanist thing to say because if you're
a womanist you want to be equal
and you have accountability as equal as
others
but if it's like 81 hours a week i was
you remove all the accountability of
people it was not me i was weak i'm a
little sheep
but you want woman you want to empower
women but they were weak i got it
just more power i don't know what to do
when people have more power i just
it it it's the inconsistency for me
rough
the amount of people who slide in the
dm's trying to be like yo say i have a
single i'm trying to go on a date
are you telling me all those people are
potential victims oh trust me they have
zero self-control they have zero agency
ooh they slide all right this is the
whole
winter olympics bruh it's just wild so
fifty shades of sliding my friend that's
crazy bro oh yeah we're all good
man shut up all of them are victorious
that was going on if you got this they
were talking
they were empowered by some bye-bye some
magical
bruh twitter twitters are talk
successful if you if you get your cues
from twitter
if you're getting your values and your
ideas from twitter i feel bad for you
oh yeah it has zero real world
applications something wrong
they try to cancel a whole b bear with
an egg account
[Music]
anyways
foreign
[Music]
hmm